très jolie ainsi très grand 9 hectares
de fruits de légumes ou encore d'herbes
aromatiques
situé en plein coeur du centre
historique de versailles le potager du
roi été construit par jean baptiste de
la quintinie à la demande du roi louis
xiv qui était féru de jardinage
il est classé monument historique et
jardins remarquables
j'imaginais pas que ce soit aussi grand
c'est assez respectueux je trouve ça
garder quand même l'esprit naturel et
puis bah on va c'est sympa qui est des
petits bord du petit chef c'est un lieu
que j'aime bien où je viens parfois
acheter des légumes parce qu'ils
produisent aussi des légumes
et puis c'est quand même nos ancêtres
qui ont mis ce potager au point
habituellement fermés au public ce lieu
confidentiel ouvre gratuitement ses
portes à l'occasion d' esprit jardin
cette année le potager du roi fait
également partie de la programmation de
la première biennale d'architecturé de
paysage de versailles
l'idée c'est de mettre en valeur la
relation entre la ville et la production
alimentaire
la villa doit être pour exister
alimenter alimenter que ce soit en
produits alimentaires mais aussi en
idées en construction en énergie et donc
c'est ça quand on essaie de mettre en
valeur aujourd'hui ici avec le temps
capricieux vous n'avez pas pu tout
découvrir sur la production de ses
fruits et légumes qui firent la renommée
de la table du roi soleil
sachez que jusqu'à mi juillet plusieurs
visites sont organisées